i'm sure we've all seen this warning
message in the past please note that
winrar is not free software after a
40-day trial period you must either buy
a license or remove it from your
computer but the funny part is that even
after the 40-day trial period expires
nothing happens winrar doesn't block you
from using the program nor do they force
you to uninstall the software
in fact you can just close this window
and continue using winrar as if you paid
for it you don't have to keep
downloading new travel versions of
winrar or find a cracked version of the
software but i'm sure all of y'all
already knew that because this is
precisely what everyone does this isn't
some sort of glitch either the company
behind winrar is well aware of the
situation and they actively allow users
to easily bypass their paywall
it's also not like winrar runs any ads
or sells your data so they truly don't
make any money from users who refuse to
buy a license
considering this why was this virtually
free software created it who actually
ends up paying and how does winrar even
make money
well starting off with the history of
winrar when rare is by no means a new
piece of software when roar was launched
way back on april 22 1995 by two
brothers named eugene and alexander
rauschel eugene was the brains behind
the operation and took care of all the
coding behind winrar meanwhile alexander
worked on the marketing and distribution
of a software by trade eugene was a
software engineer so he was well aware
of all the strengths and weaknesses of
early computers and one of their biggest
weaknesses was limited storage the
obvious solution for most people was to
simply buy more storage when they ran
out but eugene felt that there was a
better solution
what if you could have the same data
take up less space this wasn't a new
idea by any means but eugene had a
special twist on the idea
you see the vast majority of data
compression software that was available
in the 1980s was lossy based compression
as the name suggests this means that
part of the data is lost during
compression for example if you were
compressing a 4k image you could
substantially reduce the size of the
file by having its resolution but this
is obviously not the best solution
eugene's goal was to create a lossless
data compression algorithm and this led
him to creating the rar file format but
wait a minute how does lossless data
compression even work how can you store
the same data within a smaller space
without losing any data well the key is
to leverage natural redundancies within
the data itself for example let's take a
piece of text if you wanted to save this
code onto your computer the most
rudimentary method would be to go letter
by letter you could tell the computer
that the first character is i and the
second character is t and the third
character is a space and so on and so
forth but a far more efficient method
would be to tell the computer that the
character in the 1st 17th 23rd 31st and
34th positions are all the letter i
now of course that's an extremely basic
form of data compression but that's the
overall premise the idea is to eliminate
redundant data storage as much as
possible by using algorithms machine
learning and partial matching etc
anyway after grinding for quite some
time eugene came up with a new file
format called rawr 1993 and two years
later he would release a piece of
software that could compress data into
it and out of the raw file format and
this marked the birth of winrar given
that the software was free to try it
didn't take long for winrar to gain
popularity within the computer market
after all most users were desperate for
storage this isn't nearly as relatable
nowadays given that we have loads of
storage not to mention it external
storage options as well as cloud storage
options are both cheaper than ever and
this is one of the main reasons that the
popularity of winrar has been on a
massive decline over the past decade but
back in the day computers had extremely
limited storage so you had to be super
careful with what you stored anyway
eugene continuously launched newer
versions of winrar that implemented the
latest data compression technology and
over time rawr along with zip became the
standard for file compression
alright so now that we discussed the
history of winrar let's take a look at
the paid version of winrar more
specifically let's look at what exactly
the paid version offers over the free
version by far the biggest benefit that
you get from paying for winrar is that
you don't have to close the buy page
window every time you open winrar but
that's pretty much it you're basically
paying 29 to remove this pesky window
and of course be on the right side of
the moral compass
this may not sound like a big perk at
first glance but if you use winrar on a
regular basis you'll spend hours closing
these pesky windows throughout your
entire lifetime a fellow youtuber named
rmdtech actually has a full breakdown on
how much time you can save by purchasing
the license and why it's well worth the
investment jokes aside though no one
gives a crap about having to close this
window not to mention it there are
plenty of easy ways to get rid of this
window with top ping not that i
recommend that of course but
realistically the entire program is
basically free for everyday people
this might sound like a stupid business
move but there's actually multiple
legitimate reasons behind this starting
with popularity it is possible to make
software secure enough to deter the vast
majority of pirates i mean just take a
look at mac os
yes it is possible to install mac os on
a windows machine but actually getting
through all the kernel errors and driver
issues takes well over 10 hours and most
people just don't care enough to go
through that the thing to note however
is that this does not mean that the user
is just not going to use a computer at
all chances are they're just going to
part a piece of software that's easier
to pirate within the os space this was
windows and this is one of the main
reasons that windows is so popular if
windows wasn't easy to pirate it's very
possible the dominant os would have been
linux but since windows was easy most
people just stopped right there this
same rule applies to winrar as well if
it was hard to pirate winrar people
would have likely just used zip instead
or maybe some other file format would
have risen to the top so offering winrar
for free to the public was basically an
investment for the company to get the
public on their side once they have the
public on their side they've basically
already won it because companies will
have to follow suit now of course
there's going to be some oddball
companies out there that force customers
to use some obscure file format but the
vast majority will just adopt what the
public is already used to this doesn't
just apply to customers either employees
are also part of the public and if
winrar is what employees are most
familiar with that's what companies are
most likely going to use
this is the key reason that software
like microsoft office and adobe's
creative suite are so common amongst
companies and schools if you get the
public on your side institutions will
follow and unlike the public the
institutions will actually pay
as an everyday person there's really no
reason to pay for
unless you simply want to support the
developers and if that's you that's
great but at the same time you don't
really risk anything by not paying this
is not the same case with companies
though sure it wouldn't be that hard for
companies to just pirate like everyone
else but this is simply not worth the
consequences and i'm not talking about
legal consequences sure when rockets sue
them and they'll have to go through the
hassle of a lawsuit but that's not the
biggest concern the biggest concern is
the reputational risk you're taking by
pirating software and that's simply not
worth it especially given how cheap
winrar is if you're buying licenses for
over a thousand employees you only have
to pay immediately six dollars per
license if it gets leaked however that
your company has been using pirated
software you'll be paying a far greater
price for example let's say apple needs
to use winrar for whatever reason apple
currently has about 150 000 employees
and let's say 10 000 of these employees
need access to winrar at six dollars per
license that's a lifetime cost of sixty
thousand dollars
now let's say apple tried to avoid this
cost and prior to winrar and that this
eventually got leaked surely there will
be people who will no longer be willing
to shop at apple because they don't want
to support a mega cap that's actively
screwing over a small business out of
the 100 million phones apple sells every
year even if only 100 customers made
this choice apple would lose out on 80
000 worth of revenue and 800 per phone
now what if a thousand customers decide
to stop shopping at apple then we're
looking at an 800 000 revenue hit at 10
000 customers we're looking at an 8
million revenue hit keep in mind that 10
000 phones is just 0.01
of apple's annual volume so even if
pioneering winrar only pissed off 0.01
percent of just their iphone customer
base apple would be missing out on
millions of dollars worth of revenue and
we're not even considering recurring
revenue from these customers this issue
gets exponentially worse if we're
talking about a software company for
example what if it got leaked that adobe
or microsoft wasn't paying for winrar in
this scenario the company that's trying
to sell you software isn't paying for
software themselves what better path do
customers need to just pirate the
company's software at this point even
customers who would generally pay for
the software would consider pirating it
clearly this would not be a very
favorable outcome and it's more than
enough motivation for companies to
simply pay for all their software
in the end winrar was basically the
godfather of the freemium business model
just get users on your side and then
figure out monetization later when they
first leveraged this model in the 1990s
it was quite a bold move but today many
of the businesses that we come across on
a daily basis use the same model i mean
when was the last time that you paid for
instagram or facebook or google or
snapchat none of these companies have a
pop-up window that tells you that the
service is not free and that you have to
pay for it but at the core they all make
money in similar manners once they have
you on their side they offer some sort
of service to companies and it's the
companies that pay for you nowadays this
model has actually become so popular
that it's unique if you don't leverage
it for example the selling point of some
new search engines and social media
platforms is that they don't collect
your data they're either decentralized
nonprofit organizations or they directly
charge customers for their use youtube
premium is a perfect example of this it
doesn't look like winrar is trying to
hop onto this new trend though they've
become iconic for their 40 day draw
period that's actually infinite and i
don't think they're looking to change
that also based on google trends it
looks like winrar is on its way out
that's the demand for file compression
amongst everyday people is slowly dying
off according to this website they still
pull in 21 million worth of revenue and
to give in that they run an extremely
lean operation and they're likely still
profiting millions per year
so while they probably won't become the
next adobe it looks like they've got us
all the business that works for them and
that won't be changing anytime soon do
you guys still use winrar comment that
down below
also drop a like if you're still trying
out winrar and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest for your video ideas and
consider subscribing see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]
you